who is the strongest pirate in all of
One Piece looking at all fights and
powers in the story led me to a
character that no one expected it wasn't
an enemy that Luffy has faced or will
face in the story at all and it wasn't
any of the yonko either even though
kaido was known as the strongest
creature he was defeated a lot and same
goes for Whitebeard known as the
strongest men who was on the same level
as Goldie Roger his rival instead Oda
Dropped a Bomb revealing the strongest
pirates in all of One Piece to be one of
the most important people that lived
before Luffy and that three out of the
four original yonko all served under
this man rocks D zabek 38 years ago
rocks wanted to take over the world and
had the power to do so he attacked the
island of God Valley home to the rulers
of the one piece world the government
was so desperate to take him down that
he took an alliance between Marines
under the leadership of Luffy's
grandfather GARP and the crew of the
pirate king Roger to finally take him
down